Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P..
Here's an interesting observation from one of
our viewers about what they see as a decline in
obvious online trolls coinciding with
Russian sanctions. Take a listen.
Speaker 6: Hi, David. Is it me or have you also
noticed a lot less, if not almost a complete halt
of these so-called all-American or right wing
trolls that used to plague social media and,
to be honest, the internet in general? Well,
everywhere I've been going, whether it's Reddit,
Facebook or YouTube, et cetera, et cetera, I'm
noticing less and less of these online trolls
suspiciously. It seems to me that they correlate
with the sanctions against Russia. Hmm.
Do you think this could be a coincidence? Do you
think these are paid actors? We know for a fact
that a lot of these are paid actors. I just
thought I'd like to know your take on that.
And if you've noticed that or some of
your viewers have noticed that as well.
Speaker 1: So interestingly enough, I have
noticed that. But how can I even explain
this when you when you do what I do? You
start to get a sense when you take a 30000
foot view of the replies that I get on Twitter
and the YouTube comments and the Reddit posts,
you start to get a very top level view of sort of
like, what's the theme? And it is very much true
that what was previously overwhelmingly this kind
of like nationalistic, pro-American anti-communist
sort of propaganda that sometimes is associated
with Russian troll farms like the Internet
Research Agency and others. That stuff does seem
to have declined a little bit. And instead, what
we're seeing is very similar type of activity,
like brand new accounts that only post to our
subreddit or brand new accounts that are leaving
almost identical different accounts, leaving
almost identical pro-Putin messages on our YouTube
channel. There seems to have been a shift from
some of that hard right all-American nationalist
trolling to kind of like pro-Putin pro-Russia
trolling that spreads disinformation about Ukraine
and insists Ukraine is filled with Nazis and kind
of furthering that's up. I would be lying if I if
I said I didn't notice it. That being said, I want
to be really careful because there also could be
sort of like an availability bias of sorts where
we're covering Russia, Ukraine more. So it may
just be that I'm looking at more comments related
to that part of the world, and so I'm noticing
them more. But I would be lying if I said I didn't
notice the exact same thing the caller is saying.
So if there were if there were truth to it, if we
could empirically show the American nationalist
trolling is down and the pro-Putin trolling is up,
it's theoretically possible that this is just
a shift in the priorities of these Russian
troll farms, which are very sophisticated, quite
frankly, and they're just kind of shifting their
message. That's totally plausible. It also could
be that all of us are just paying attention more
to Russia and Ukraine. And so if you're watching
10 Russia Ukraine videos a week instead of none
and then you look at the comments, you're
going to notice a lot more pro-Putin propaganda
naturally than the hard right American stuff,
because that's just the subject matter of the
videos you're looking at. So I think what the
caller is saying is interesting. We'd have to
study it and study it empirically, and that's not
something that I've done. But I'm curious to hear
whether people in the audience are seeing the same
thing on today's bonus show. Calls for the United
States to ban Russian oil are getting momentum,
gaining momentum, despite concerns about it
accelerating inflation even more. We will also
talk as we have spoken before about the reality
that not every military conflict or invasion
or war gets the same media coverage. We'll talk
about why and we'll talk about the consequences
of that. And lastly, high schools could lose AP
classes, advanced placement classes if they ban
so-called required topics from being taught.
And we're going to talk about what those topics
are and much more. I will reminisce about my AP
econ class that I took in high school, which first
got me interested in economics and led to me doing
economics at the undergraduate and graduate level
in college. AP really had a big impact on me,
and losing those classes would be a very, very
bad thing. You can get access to the bonus show
instantly by signing up at Join Packman dot com.
Unidentified: I will see you that.